vous pas ça. Voici la suite.
- Le gentlement cambrioleur
est de retour sur Netflix pour
une 2e saison, 5 mois après
avoir pulvérisé des records
et conquis des millons de fans
partout sur la planète.
"Lupin" s'est classée numéro 1
dans une dizaine de pays,
dont les États-Unis.
- On m'a piégé.
- Avec ses plus de 75 millions
de visionnements en 28 jours,
elle a même dépassée
la populaire série espagnole
Casa Del Papel...
- Vous devez tenir
votre promesse.
- ...la série non anglophone
la plus populaire sur Netflix.
- L'homme le plus recherché
de France.
- Lupin, c'est l'histoire
d'Assane Diop, interprété
par Omar Sy, un admirateur
d'Arsène Lupin, qui s'inspire
de son héros d'enfance pour
venger la mort de son père,
accusé à tort d'un crime par
un homme riche et machiavelique
pour qui il travaillait.
Outre le mélange action,
suspense et comédie, un des
secrets du succès de la série,
c'est l'habile campagne
promotionnelle qui distille
sur les réseaux sociaux
des indices et des énigmes.
Par exemple, à la fin
de la bande-annonce
de la nouvelle saison,
un lien subtilement dissimulé
nous guide vers un site Web qui
confirme que la série reviendra
pour une troisième partie.
Ou encore quand Omar Sy
est allé coller des affiche
dans le métro pour prouver
qu'il pouvait vraiment
passer incognito.
- C'est très gentil.
- La première saison comptait
seulement cinq épisodes,
mais ça a suffi pour faire
exploser les ventes des livres
en France, mais au Québec aussi.
Moi, j'avais beaucoup aimé la
première saison. Louis-Philippe,
est-ce que la deuxième saison
est à la hauteur des attentes?
- Moi, Nabi, mes attentes
étaient supers élevées parce que
j'ai adoré la première saison.
Bon, l'effet de surprise n'est
plus du tout là pour les cinq
nouveaux épisodes. Beaucoup
plus hollywoodien. Il y a
les revirements, certains
ne sont absolument pas crédibles
du tout. Mais tu sais, d'un
autre côté, c'est un plaisir
coupable. Pourquoi? J'ai dévoré
les cinq nouveaux épisodes
en deux soirées seulement. Donc,
il faut voir ça quand même.
- Bon, bon, bon, projet
de week-end. Merci beaucoup,
Louis-Philippe.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier
et Louis-Philippe Ouimet,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.